hey what's up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
this is my full review of one of my
newest favorite pairs of headphones
under $200 the Bayer dynamic custom Pro
ones and they're my favorites for a lot
more than the fact that they have red in
black on them but I haven't done
headphone reviews in a while so if you
want to see more headphone reviews or
similar lower budget accessories and
things like that definitely the thumbs
up below or comment if you have more
suggestions but let's go ahead and dive
right into this these are the Bayer
dynamic custom Pro one headphones and
they kind of came into my world out of
nowhere in the past month and just
became my daily driver over the ear
headphones which is kind of a big deal
for me for a while I've hailed the a THM
50s by Audio Technica as my favorite
headphones under $200 buy a lot for a
long time if you want to watch that
infamous review I guess you can check
out that link right below the like
button on this video but you can thank
TLD today for introducing me to these
very dynamic cans as they've surprised
me quite a bit in a really good way
headphones are catching up to the M 50s
now and this one is what I've seen the
leader of the pack first of all these
headphones look good and I don't say
that about a lot of headphones there are
a lot of very ugly headphones out there
but these actually look really good like
beats Pro good sexy some might say now
I'm not just saying this because they
have a little bit of red and black in
fact you can actually customize the
plates on these the entire look to make
them look like a totally different set
of headphones
hence the name the custom so you can
really do whatever you want with these
the velcro on the top is changeable and
everything I chose all black with the
red accents but these are also sexy for
more than just the color but also the
materials used and the overall form and
function and the feel of these
headphones they honestly stand out to me
of some of the best-looking ones now the
second reason to love these over the
eight ehm 50s is features these have two
very specific features that are better
than or at least are not included on the
80 HM 50s first is the removable
headphone cable it comes with a cable
that's about three feet long and it's
very manageable but at the end is a
removable headphone jack with a slot
that actually plugs into the bottom of
the left side of the headphones so that
makes them actually really versatile if
you break the cable you can replace it
with a new one and I've actually seen
them with a
movable microphone attachment so you can
attach an inline microphone and that
makes these now you know gaming
headphones you can use them for Skype or
phone calls or gaming whatever else you
want to do which is cool I wouldn't use
it for that but it's definitely a value
adding feature and then the second
awesome feature that separates it from
my favorites the m50 s are the base port
now this is a port at the bottom of each
can on the bottom of these headphones
that are a seriously unique feature that
almost no other pair has it's basically
a slider that adjusts how much these
headphones respond to bass or the low
frequencies the more open the port is
the more bass you have in your sound now
a lot of people will cry this is BS that
does not work is this effective does
this actually make a difference in the
sound yes it actually does and not only
can I hear it boom here is a graph of
the frequency response with the
different positions as you notch forward
and as you can see halfway down open is
where I keep it and that's approximately
the most balanced sound and that's where
it sounds close to the m50 s actually so
I got used to the sound pretty quick but
this is a seriously awesome feature say
you're listening to jazz and you just
want to accentuate you know the vocals
and you want to concentrate on the highs
and mids of the instrumentals so you
switch over to closing all of the
baseboards and you hear all that and
then you switch over to listening to you
know Skrillex on Pandora and you just
open up the bass board and unleash the
full rockin bass that these things are
capable of just with the flick of a
switch I mean that's some serious
versatility right there that is a killer
feature of these headphones so yeah
these guys are good-looking enough to
have some unique features and be really
compelling and I have switched over to
these as my full-time editing and music
listening over ear headphones from the
EM 50s and I don't regret it at all
these guys are comfortable flexible and
pretty soft so they will fit in just
about any size head they don't fold the
same way that the m50 s do and they're
also not as flexible so I guess they're
not really portable because they don't
come with a can or a way to port them
but then again the m50 s are
ridiculously stretchy so I wouldn't
expect any other parrot to live up to
that but I do like the fact that these
guys are fairly compact without having
to fold them one thing to note is that
these actually do have to be burned in a
little bit they didn't sound fantastic
out the box but they do sound pretty
good
now so if you do get these just lay them
on a table play some music for a couple
of hours maybe overnight maybe for a day
or two and you'll you'll gradually start
to hear the sound stage open up and
they'll really start to pop now I can't
go into audio file level detail on the
sound but I've been listening to these
without an amp for a while so they sound
really good without an amp they're
pretty sensitive and like I said they
sound similar to the EM 50s when the
bass port is half open so you get very
deep rich lows but they're still
detailed enough to have plenty of room
for the mids and the highs an overall
very balanced sound works well in a lot
of situations but really being able to
play around with your sound and the bass
port is something that I'm going to
start looking forward to in future
headphones bottom line I recommend these
the bass port is a ton of fun to play
around with the link below has your
price and they're in the same ballpark
as the EM 50s so it's definitely an
option you really can't go wrong with
these or either set for that matter but
I guess it's just a matter of which one
you think looks better so go ahead and
pull the trigger and you won't regret it
these are the Bayer dynamic custom one
Pro headphones thank you for watching
I'll talk to you guys in the next video
and don't buy the Facebook phone peace
you